the conjuring the devil made me do it
available in theaters and streaming
exclusively on
hbo max today back in the role of ed
warren
is none other than the uh actor
patrick wilson how are you patrick i'm
good buddy how you doing
i am better for talking to you i'm
better for talking to you
um so back in the role of ed warren a
paranormal uh
investigator um he's been at this a
while you've been at this
a lot i i i
literally can't seem to find all the
demons so i have to keep uh
keep looking i mean what else are you
gonna do
i've looked everywhere have you really
looked everywhere though patrick i mean
like i mean at this point in time
oh my gosh what is it like to return to
a role
uh in your career here yeah no you know
what's funny
is you you rarely get this opportunity
and i
i it's easy to say oh my god you've done
three of them we've actually meeting me
and beer for me again played these roles
this is our
fourth time uh playing ed lorraine
warren
um but i gotta say it's a complete
luxury i mean we have a blast working
together
you know our movies hopefully are really
scary to people but we also try to find
the
heart and the humor and all that so it's
um it's it's actually
it's a it's a it's a real blessing
because
a lot of times you know you'll sign sql
deals for things and you hope oh
god i don't even want to do this again
and and we're real lucky that that we
have fun making the movies and that they
work because
as you know rarely do things both be
financially successful
and super enjoyable for you did you know
it's a win-win did you grow up
and liking these types of movies
watching these types of movies
no not not really i mean i you know i
was a
certainly a big movie guy but not um
i wasn't i wasn't a horror guy i really
wasn't and it was just my
relationship with uh with james juan who
i
directed the first two conjuring and we
did aquaman together i did another
series called uh insidious couple of
movies with him doing that
um and it was really our relationship
and just it was a lot of
i loved it you know i really did i i
felt like it it it actually got me out
of my comfort zone i
you know i i used to do a lot of theater
and a lot of musical theaters
and when i got into movies most of the
stuff that i did was
was pretty um how do i say it i
underplayed a lot of things it was very
sort of natural and it was actually
it was it was really rewarding to just
sort of go out there and really
just let it rip and you know scream and
yell and damn the
devil back to hell you know if you will
good yes and you know i mean obviously
you've been nominated for tony uh for
your work
on uh on the stage and angels in america
along with also obviously the phantom of
the opera which you were in that film
i loved jen fargo on tv what a great tv
show
that is and was certainly the season you
were in
on that what was it like to to work on
on a tv series based on such a uh
a remarkable movie in fargo yeah no it
it was fantastic i mean that movie is is
always been one of my favorites and i
i actually by the time i got the job for
the
when they offered me the second season i
hadn't seen the first season i and i i
was sort of like you i just felt like
i mean this movie is so revered how do
you do a tv show right
and then honestly one conversation with
noah hawley the the
the show runner and really just guru
behind that whole series um
writer director um producer he just he
sold me on it and it was you know a
similar tone but a different story and
um and it was awesome you know it's
funny actors
tend to guys that play the good guy a
lot
you know you always want to play the
villain or the um or the character parts
but i gotta say playing lou salverson in
fargo was one of the best roles of my
life because he was
it was everything that you want to be he
was just that
good and solid of a guy you know that
would never back down from anything
but just a pure heart and like man this
guy makes me feel dirty
um so it was it was fantastic and plus
you know you you worked with a
television uh
acting legend in ted danson what was
that like to be on the set with his head
my
my carnegie mellon fellow carnegie
mellon alumni yeah um alumnus
yeah um i mean one of the one of the
best
honestly he is um he's one of the best
i i i for a guy that did was so
successful in tv
he's uh he's so natural and effortless
in in in in making it look natural
and effortless which is of course the
goal of every
actor like you don't you know if you see
somebody working you're like ooh they're
really working but
you know my i would rather you just go
ah it looks like it fits him looks like
looks like that was easy and then i've
done my job because you should be
convinced again
and ted is just the the one of those
guys that can go in and out between
comedy and drama he's so funny
so charismatic um and a great dude
just a great guy to boot we spent a lot
of time together patrick wilson here on
the rich eisen show the conjuring the
devil made me do it is in theaters today
also on
hbo max um so what are your sports teams
which teams do you root for um wilson i
grew up in tampa bay okay i'm a big buck
fan
big bold fan belief we've had a lovely
year you sure have
my gosh you sure i know i know it's been
awesome actually
yes i did that the that nfl athon thing
yes i remember that last
year yes you and and i and i wore my
little hat
and i everyone mocked me for my not
everybody on your show but
everyone you know oh yeah you're a buck
fan oh sorry sorry oh god remember 2003
yeah yeah yeah yeah just keep waiting so
i was i was super excited for that
um big year for campus sports yes it
certainly helps to
have tom brady when you want to flex you
know what i'm saying it certainly
happened
certainly yes it does but i mean what a
year i mean it was the city of champions
for crying out loud unbelievable
unbelievable the rays have been on a
great run um now they're with the
yankees and and i was
i mean i'm a huge sports fan and i've
been in you know in and around new york
longer than i actually ever lived in
saint pete right in tampa bay so i was a
i was a yankee fan before i was a race
fan because they're
when i was there there were no race we
would go watch spring training and
i was a card fan as a kid so uh and my
dad was actually uh
close friends with the boss so uh george
steinberg actually set me up with my
first
meeting with an agent i should have
never said that before but it's true
um so hold on a second i've got to stop
you so funny
hold on a second you patrick wilson your
father tight with george
george m steinbrenner iii is that what
you're saying yes
yes my well in camp my a little back
story so my
my dad was a tv anchor uh
at wtvt down there for god you know uh
he was an
anchor for 50 years and he was in tampa
for 30. my brother's the anchor now and
my dad
my mom always did this um this christmas
show that the steinbrenner's
put on and and uh for all at-risk kids
and it's an amazing event they do every
year my brother now does it so
my point is over the past 25 years my
dad became very close with uh with
the steinbrenner family so um and it was
always one of those things well hey
you know your kid's gonna be an actor
well hey when you need when you need uh
some help give me a call and you're
always like yeah come on yes you're
george stephen better
and sure enough i wanted to go out i was
in college and i wanted to meet
an agent and uh and sure enough within a
phone call because
he knew so and so i mean he knew
everybody of course um and yeah
set me up with an agent that went in and
they were like why are you here and i
was like
my dad's friends with george
ridiculous just pulling out every every
every stop
why not pretty awesome by the way why
not by the way i like the way that you
telling the story using the larry david
voice for steinbrenner i thought it was
outstanding patrick
i caught that because that's the way he
did sound i mean that's the way he
talked
you know unbelievable it just like you
just it was
it was awesome he was he was the thing
is when you're
when you know that family down in tampa
yes different than
obviously clearly much different than
your experience as a new yorker through
the through the lens of of
of the yankees but down there because he
was so active in the community and all
the
uh the the philanthropy that he did it
was it was uh
they're just an amazing family so we've
always had a great relationship with
them
no i'm just talking about i've never
talked about the time writers before i
love it patrick wilson this is the type
of show for you to do it on right now
and certainly i'm a native new yorker
i'm from staten island new york a
die-hard yankee fan and
so i grew up with a front-row seat to
steinbrenner's 70s yankees 80s 90s on
and obviously all the way through to
through through his passing
uh you then would definitely have to
agree that if he was alive today you
would definitely not be professing your
love for anybody other than the yankees
on
on television very
and i will tell you i will tell you in
the mid 90s when the race finally came
came up right i could still wear both
hats i could wear the raised hat
the devil my my original devil jersey i
could wear them in new york
because they were like oh in that sweet
oh look at you
wearing the losers you know and it
wasn't really until early 2000s you know
obviously close to 2008 when they when
they got really close
that you felt like uh oh god do i have
to pick
um and that's the story of an actor it's
sort of like wherever you you land is
you know your home but i i carry such a
deep pride for my
hometown team as well yeah it is like
that seinfeld episode where
elaine was told to take the orioles hat
off sitting in yankee stadium
that's real that's right hey i
so okay so during the
when the when the red sox won in o4 and
i uh a dear friend of mine uh jody
manchevich who's married to doug mcdavid
um i sat with the red sox wives in
yankee stadium i said listen
you're a friend of mine i know you since
the fourth grade i i i cannot i'm not
cheering for the red
sox in the wives section like i i won't
be a jerk i want you for the yankees
right
um but that was a very you know i just
because you got that it's it's like code
like i'm in yankee stadium
how many red socks on straw um and she
perfectly understood as i sat with all
the red sox
wives very quietly cheering for my uh
for the yankees um and then of course
they left saying ah we probably won't be
back
and then of course they came back no i
know
oh but it's so sensitive this sort of
stuff i love it
i love it i love it patrick wilson here
uh on the rich eisen show and so
i mean congrats on everything that
you've you've you've done in your career
aquaman obviously uh
do you get a lot uh walking around you
know now that we're post-pandemic or
pre-pandemic about
aquaman is that the thing that you get a
lot because of how
remarkably um wide released and
successful that was
patrick you know i
i get probably more from the from the
from the horror movies because
they get they yeah from conjuring and
and and
and insidious too i think because of uh
because the way that those movies hit
people and and aquaman because i'm
you know underwater and this crazy
blonde hair people
you know i'm i'm i'm i'm not as easily
recognized for some reason right
um but yeah i kind of drift in and out
look like every other white guy okay
i'm i'm okay and how well do you how old
do you swim patrick you're good swimmer
now
i swear what i grew up in tampa bay i
grew up on the water i'm
i'm i'm quite the swimmer i'm getting
this yeah plus
steinberg got you your own natatorium
back in the day i'm sure
well there's that there's that i'm sure
yeah
i am wait a minute george can do
everything it's amazing the conjuring
george made me do it
available right now and theaters near
you
the conjuring the devil made me do it
available in theaters and streaming
exclusively on hbo max today
patrick thanks for the call let's do
this more often certainly since
your tampa bay teams keep winning so
congrats on that yes that's good
you got it at patrickwilson73 on twitter
at the real
reel patrick wilson on instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here